yo yo yo what is up my name is Mark mu
for life 420 blaze it and I'm here with
five nights of [ __ ] boys three here to
show you a good time and a night of
debauchery I'm gonna get crunk I'm gonna
play a game I'm gonna meet up with my
good friends we're gonna have a fun time
okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to five nights at
[ __ ] boys 3 now oddly enough
after I finished five nights at [ __ ]
boys to five nights to [ __ ] boy three
kind of just released and everyone's
like oh my god you got a roll right into
that and play it and I was like I need
to give my liver a bit of a break here I
don't drink all that much and drinking
like two days in the same week was
overkill for me but now it's been a good
long break and I've been eager to play
this one because I actually thoroughly
enjoyed the last one so you know what
time it is it's time to go back to the
skull glasses because no way I'm gonna
take double shots for as long as this
game may or may not be because there I
don't think there is one either by a
walk throughout by now but anyway it's
gonna be a fun time and I'm looking
forward to it because hey I had a blast
the last time and people love the love
of these games for some reason I don't
know why maybe it's because they were
playing the drinking game along with me
and they got so drunk that they forgot
that I was a blip ring blubbering idiot
so either way get ready for another
adventure if you're watching this in the
future and you waited for the whole
playlist to come out before joining me
it is gonna be a fun drinking game for
you and me but either way Bottoms Europe
ah that was nice mmm okay
warning certain visual effects used in
this game may be harmful for those who
suffer from epilepsy okay that's a
warming sensation down my throat mmm
select a difficulty okay I'm gonna just
go standard because I don't think I will
be able to conquer the other higher
difficulty there are copyrighted song in
this game disable them yes the music
industry would be very offended if I use
that no don't log in a game Joel I don't
even have a game Joel to count fazbear's
fright the horror attraction spring-trap
must reach the office to achieve
terminal debauchery the fate of the oh
okay the fate of the world depends on
please enlist I think this is what's it
nine five why are we starting on night
five also like how am I gonna get like
who's gonna be in my party see I don't
know anything about this one other than
it takes place oh cool ah clever [ __ ] I
got yeah I understand what we owe
oh there we go okay yay two copper coils
will found ok good what does that do for
me how do i we're doing what oh oh oh
wait why did that improve Matt oh it
didn't okay okay alright there's gonna
be a little bit of getting used to but I
do know that I'm very excited for this
oh because he's so enclosed and impaled
on the interior spikes of his suit I
cannot exit you sound very British
[Music]
time to get into this cuz I don't even
know oh demolition tweet combo okay
there we go again we just cycled up
again
yeah whoa I attacked twice Oh Oh am I
not get oh wait a minute
yeah because it's weird because every
one of the other animatronics in this in
five nights at Freddy's 3 was an
illusion of hallucination so you didn't
actually know the first victory okay so
I don't know how it's gonna represent
other teammates other than something
else actually I don't even remember like
the layout of how this is supposed to go
I know there's gonna be I know there's
got to be vents and whatnot that I need
to kill oh I did not heal I don't even
know if I had any items to heal with I'm
okay so that is convenient that I do two
attacks is that like the representation
of what my other party members would be
like like I'm gonna I'm gonna be able to
have more attacks is that what's gonna
be no that's true
oh I love being able to save whenever I
need to save it's so much nicer also
this really detailed like extremely
detailed it's a balloon boy I remember
what happened at the end of five nights
of [ __ ] boys do [ __ ] [ __ ] I am a
pathetic failure in this form curse my
limited body okay what app I didn't have
any plans anyway you just wanted a night
of terminal debauchery does that mean
deadly debauchery or is that something
else medium pizza cool it's already got
a different feel than the other games
Oh devour my [ __ ] party hat zombie party
hat
oh that meant oh I don't know if this is
a good idea oh oh there's so many things
I can do increase defense last five
turns my paralyzed anti agus oh I should
fortify because these guys are gonna
hurt oh I can't do two I can do two
things
that's so cool oh okay I get it
alright so if I just attack well this
sucks I'm gonna die ah oh we can do two
things okay as long as I can do two
things I think I'm actually gonna be
okay
that really hurts I wish you wouldn't do
that
I once again with the Japanese music
coming in during we're playing is this
j-pop or k-pop well I don't think it's
pop at all but either way possibly it's
like some remix to the other song that
was in five nights of [ __ ] boys - hey
I'm almost done don't worry I won't
I won't be making you guys go through
all the battles unless I have something
to say when I'm doing it and everyone
knows the barbwire always has important
things to say whenever he's playing the
game key shard alpha reach level five
learn type anti anima no not the animu
everyone loves you yeah me british
spring-trap um bad party hat go die yeah
hapless Wow spring-trap is sassy oh
really cut to the bone there why isn't
Balloon Boy talking did Balloon Boy have
a voice in the other one I don't even
know he did I think they just
synthesized it with the laughing
whatever oh yeah come on there are kids
watching this probably and you shouldn't
be go to Brad I've realized the error of
my ways I've now turned over a new leaf
okay okay all right I forgive and forget
everything that happened when you were
the ultimate evil and I kicked your ass
so oh you're not even gonna sue do the
thing say the thing before celli fine
debauchery hearing that word makes me
cringe my [ __ ] eyes out
okay pretty much that's about right yeah
that's about right too spring-trap is a
smart and sassy sue I almost like this
character whereas Freddy before it was
just kind of a passive-aggressive douche
nozzle well I was actually kind of sad
it was just like well I mean I guess
Balloon Boy was like the ultimate evil
in the last one there we go in a special
British voice inhale my dong enragement
child okay what do you get how much fun
oh I got any tokens okay oh man there's
so much stuff spring traps whip why does
spring-trap have a whip in the naughty
adults box you know at Freddy fazbear's
pizza there's the kids prize box and
then there's the naughty adult prize box
where it's not good it's a bad idea they
got rid of it no no no okay so either
way I need that I need that I probably
need this and then I need more of these
and I guess there's no resurrection to
be had because if I die it's just like
flat-out game over is that not wrong
okay oh okay that's good enough save it
up go go go go nope go where am I going
I don't know where I'm going chica
you're not gonna say oh oh you're a
ghost I can't do that
hearing you talk to me like that from
the great beyond sets of fire to my
loins I miss you so much chica not
really at all okay all right Kirby see
now I'm actually gonna have to be very
observant in this game because I know
there's probably a lot of secrets that I
do know about and I'm not one to like
console
hey Bonnie honey your voice got better
I'm not Freddy I'm spring-trap baby come
on not a better debauchery than Freddy
ever was if you were gonna join me you
know great time okay whatever okay [ __ ]
oh I shouldn't be here there's only oh
it does say power power of three okay I
should get out of here I should go back
to this area and I should farm up a bit
but before I do that I want to know
kinda know the limitations of where I
can go because if I don't explore I'm
never gonna find what I need okay
arcade enjoy video classics from the
ripe year 1990 ex as all like Mega Man
games and stuff like that just mm and ex
chicas oven party and is there gonna be
some avian behinds involved with this
and my B to blow skills need to come
into play I'm just needing a baseline
before I walk my into this
okay he's very excited then I suppose I
should be too
I love the pauses in between
springtrap's thought process like his
computer just can't handle all the
awesome oh crap early beta just brought
in a sec this is gonna kill me isn't I'm
running anyway screw that I ain't
following up on that because I don't
think I could win and I don't oh no oh
no okay so I had a mini heart attack the
game crashed on me but I didn't lose
anything I was very worried about that
because my file for the recording got
corrupted I was like oh I already took a
shot I can't redo that so what happened
is I loaded it back up and now hopefully
it won't crash cuz that's my objective
and if that doesn't happen well I won't
be screwed over and have to take another
shot and then it'll crash again and I
have to take another shot can I not go
through the vents sound nothing I can do
okay so what I didn't do while it was
down was figure out what I needed to do
but I'm just assuming it's gonna tell me
what I need to do because in five nights
at Freddy's 3 the objective was
obviously to get to the guard room but I
know that my night of debauchery
requires friends you can't debauch your
eyes without allies come on it's common
sense everybody also I am wrecking these
guys I'm wrecking these party outside
I should probably save incredibly often
because I do not want to lose any
progress
now now for those techno files I'm
recording on a screen reads and as
opposed to hooking into the game itself
so now I'll be able to if it crashes it
won't affect the recording its
recordings if recording for desktop
I didn't upgrade any of my crap I bought
all that stuff and I didn't do anything
about it okay so what I got from these
items was the
key shard alpha-1 fragment of estranged
key and I'm assuming that this key is
going to be something that unlocks in
the final room and I need to get this
item from all the party hats because
it's a 90 debauchery and without party
hats you can't have a good time or
something I don't know I'm just making
it up as a gun like in case you guys
couldn't tell I'm full [ __ ] like 90%
of my life is just [ __ ] the secret
to success is to pretend you know what
you're doing until people actually
believe that you're not an idiot and
then you keep that guys up until you
make friends and then go about your
daily life move up the corporate ladder
and then find out that your life is
hollow it haven't been sad and then you
drink away your problems
I get that chica but tell me what I need
to do I want to know okay fine
okay so I'm in a new area now this is
also level power too and I don't imagine
all these arcade games are gonna work
either because I have tokens and they're
not cool ties and you need quarters to
be able to do what you need to do oh oh
oh oh oh I shouldn't be oh you shouldn't
be here I've been punished badly spring
cops up bad boy oh okay maybe I'm not
ready for level 2 area maybe level 2
area is actually bad for my health
also we're like we're like there aren't
no cameras that I need to kill are there
no level choose a bad area I need to get
to level 1 again and then comfortably go
around here until I'm happy and fun and
free and do the thing that I need to do
which is
oh whoa whoa oh that what did you what
did I do
what do I do with it
Horry sorry oh come on what a bunch of
baloney that's my Easter egg why you son
of a [ __ ] I thought I found something
good I just got in a horrible car crash
I took out ten people
I'm an evil evil debaucher Iser they
need I need to lake it's not your house
pull up your pants I can't how would I
do that can't get me what I'm doing is
I'm just blazing ahead to try to fool
Wow all these good memories that are
flashing back to me and I still don't
want to do that no no you don't need it
that badly no no we're gonna do this
dance again apparently you're a ghost
you couldn't even use it say spring-trap
has to go through what Freddy was
already going through fine I can't Aziz
you want a necessary sex oh I suppose I
could who was it that Freddy said excuse
me possibly my portion this couldn't
handle it mmm do I pass on this what
okay what are you doing you can't charge
the door oh damn it
fine whatever I get it
oh happy birthday prepare to die I can
think I can actually run away from these
bastards
oh boy Freddy she'll cool
I cannot exit but what happens if I go
through that one is it gonna be the same
results as the other one only one way to
find out I'm beginning the thing is
actually gonna result in the same
outcome okay so now that I went over
here I kind of found we have with all
five in hand and both gatekeepers dead
the seal shall be broken and inside
you'll be led
is that like some prophetic [ __ ] going
on there what pulse and what is with
these cables what earth with these
cables I'm portion British
oh I can't look at this Oh God shield
rise kids well I mean okay all right
that's the thing that happened great
okay so what I need what I did was I
went to the end of the hallway and I got
I got an item called like the shell of
toy Freddy's head and then I think that
chica finally had her special moment
with Freddy I'm gonna assume that's what
it was but holy hell that was a thing
somewhere a mysterious portal appeared
great but how do I wash my brain of what
I just heard will bleach do it okay so
now I guess I gotta find this magical
portal that opened somewhere is the
magical poorer corner not corner portal
Horner was whatever the hell that was is
the magical portal like gonna be one of
the vents oh all right cool so hot
step into the portal you cannot save
inside well good thing I saved right
here I don't know what this magical
portal is gonna do but I'm gonna try my
hardest
is this like relating to the Easter eggs
in five nights at Freddy's 3 oh my god
look I'm spring-trap oh my god I'm gonna
die horribly okay
Oh Oh let me go I'm a little dangly do
I'm a little dude anger oh man
it's weird because this is bizarre
because this is hey I'm angle are you
how are you doing there it's weird
because why is that a 20 up in there
what is this a 20 let's say 20 up in
there what 420 do I need to blaze
something do I need to be to blaze I
don't know what that was all about but
there's got to be like 2030 hello foxy
you look a [ __ ] in grey
anyway what I'm saying is that it's
bizarre because these are the exact
graphics Oh what was going on in 5
nights 2 3 fatties free friends but five
nights at Freddy's 3 when all that went
down but it's in our PG maker which is
actually what those graphics are kind of
like so it's weird because it fits so
well into it
then it seems almost like it's meant to
be this way and in all honesty when you
realize it that five nights of [ __ ] boys
is the true experience that everyone
always wanted out of five nights at
Freddy's probably I'm guessing hi Freddy
you look good so you're 40 great was
that gonna mean for me is the purple guy
gonna come no I'm the purple guy I'm
spring-trap there is no purple guy
around here what does this all mean
I freed chica by letting her hot bird
ass be devoured by Freddy in a night of
debauchery so this is what he meant by
terminal debauchery I just need to send
all the spirits into the after world by
letting him get hot and heavy with each
other apparently no no no no I didn't
say that I didn't want this are you I
didn't want this okay but this should be
fine because what I'll do is I can take
out both of these in one hit that will
remove them all defense up for chica oh
you missed me that's too bad for you
okay so I'll be over that's right now oh
I can do backup - Wow everyone wants me
to do backup
but it misses so awesome awesome it
misses so awful often okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna defense up and
then I'm gonna smash tikka in the face
I'm a win this bout
oh how about oh I'm in trouble
oh oh oh this is embarrassing
oh now that's not good I ain't got that
good in five days you [ __ ] boys three
good why not all the logic in the world
let's get a vacuum cleaner up in here
for some damn reason okay here we go I'm
ready vacuum engage their vacuum
[ __ ] oh it's an item I put it in
my pocket fine whatever it's a little
bit too early to be this energetic and
flattered at the ran [ __ ] that is
gonna be presented in this game because
okay well I bet what I bet is a thing is
this vacuum is gonna allow me to do
something else probably like just
thinking logically I saw rocks and dirt
on floors in other places maybe I clean
them up and Balloon Boy will sell me new
[ __ ] in that new area that's just my
assumption perfect for inhaling dong of
course it is of course it is why
wouldn't it be exactly that well I know
who would want some dong inhale Manfredi
requested dong inhale Minh I've got a
heaping helping of dong inhale Minh
trenny to go cuz obviously it's not an
esoteric sex toy but it's perfect for
some Freddie
yeah get ready Bob oh no oh that's it
no Big Finish all right there we go then
now this is what I was talking about
somewhere a mysterious portal appeared
well great but that doesn't help me get
better items or fight dudes or whatever
but at least you got Freddy off
literally of this world that's a lot of
you so surprising I didn't do [ __ ] I
just got surprised bunch of the Paul oh
no no no not this I don't want to talk
to you man go get you a dragon dildo by
the way I looked up what a dragon dildo
was don't look up what a dragon dildo is
unless you're into that thing but if you
don't know what it is then don't look it
up or maybe if you're Kurt it's your
life I ain't gonna tell you what to do
okay so I since I used the vacuum on
Freddy now and because the vacuum
appeared out of nowhere for something
else I can only assume that there's
gonna be another one appearing somewhere
else but there's also got to be a way to
make Balloon Boy go into another area or
get better [ __ ] and I gotta find out how
to do that so whenever I do it's gonna
be great it's gonna be the best when I
find that how do I do that
oh oh there's that's the thing yes
what did that blanket oh that's for foxy
cuz he wants some privacy
cool I really don't know like what is
the purpose behind all this but well
jeez a little harsh don't you think
oh no oh no no no what well why does
foxy now why my rag the thought I was
gonna give what he wanted can't wait for
what I'm actually can't wait till I'm
actually strong enough to be able to use
the items that I want to use to be
honest I kind of like the fact that I
only have one character but that's
actually really interesting because when
you think about it five nights at
Freddy's one had like the limited number
of characters for the caster or five
with foxy and then five minutes of ready
sue had so many new animatronics and it
was just like yeah juggle all of them
when you were playing through it in five
nights of [ __ ] boys do and now it's just
the one just the one it even says that a
blanket that might be perfect for
masturbating foxes which is a bizarre
thing to design a blanket for
exclusively you Stevie for it is there
one I can beat one oh I didn't oh no
well five hits oh wow
okay I went back into this area because
there was one small room that I didn't
go in yet and there might be something
else here which is up this way so let me
just see
no not oh that's where you died you
don't want to go over there how about
over here on this door don't you want to
go out no okay
so I leveled up quite a bit I'm now at
level 10 and this is a 10 in here so I'm
thinking I might be able to beat this
bird and it will be good I'm trying to
be smart about this
I'm gonna use my I'm gonna use my
abilities turn your defense down turn my
offense up before I do things actually
no I need to lower her attack that way
she won't be bashing my face in there we
go I can actually do some vent ow okay
ow I didn't buy items I'm an idiot
I didn't buy items why didn't I buy
items I already said I'm an idiot listen
alright BRB damn it okay so I'm not
gonna let this chicken bait me because
I'm better than her probably maybe
that's my next objective so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna end this episode
here I know I have a reason I know this
was like probably a long episode because
I had so much that I wanted to do and I
wanted to get an idea of what my goal
was gonna be before I did it so now I
know what I'm gonna do I just need to
level up a whole bunch off of these
bastards over here I need to figure out
how to unlock the second balloon boy so
I can get better items so that I can
smash trigger you know what not like
that but I will win so thank you
everybody so much for watching I know
I'm gonna have a blast playing this game
and I hope you guys have a blast with me
if you're playing a drinking game along
with me and your drinking age have fun
with it but be responsible remember in
your power to save life there something
profound like that I believe but either
way just be responsible with what you do
and have fun in a safe way thanks
everybody so much for watching and as
boys I will see you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what